hey Mike your honor New York one of my
friends was talking about bumble there
was a cute guy on there that swiped on
she went out with him he turned out to
be Benji
she said all he could talk about was the
show like he had no identity of his own
but the real problem was his pitchers
were like 30 pounds old Benji what's a
huge wet spot on your shirt your shirt
is all soaking wet like is a big spot my
water I try to get to stand up I thought
you were sweating pretty sure I'm sure I
am to someone right so this guy's
claiming you put out a picture of
yourself 30 pounds lighter yeah yeah and
so when they see we'll listen if the
situation is reversed you go on a
website and even range a date with a
girl and you show up and she's 30 pounds
heavier I've had that I was it so you're
dating what why do you do that this girl
is so beautiful and then I meet her like
she's so beautiful skinny and it's just
like what yeah so so what an ugly the
same thing you know guys you don't Wade
this fat you're gonna get a girl name
one thing but also a guy can work his
way into a woman's life so I always say
the guys use your best pictures girls
use your worst because if a guy likes
you at your worst he's probably gonna be
into you so you better guys lit like
something that might jump in and once in
a while like that you're already saying
I've deceived you right and that's not
just when she's saying is I was
attracted to the guy in the picture I
was willing to give that guy a shot and
you lied to me she's like this guy you
know then he grew three chins since I
Benji's theory is even fat he can work
his way try but I have written in my
profile now I write really a good
profile against a lot of women I say I
work as a whole we do have a guy late in
the year that's true yeah doesn't help
so much
what's your parameters on bumble like
don't you have to set certain
limitations about what you want a woman
you can't constantly change it so right
now I could say I want to only look at
women
like 30 to 45 what are your parameters I
changed it all tonight you can also go
80 to 100 so if I went today well right
now like last night I went I think 18 to
100 and 100 miles away up to 100 miles
away
we keep sliding it north you can keep
doing it are you feeling particularly
desperate yesterday no no I just it's
it's very fun I'm looking at these
parameters Ben she's not willing to go
to Norway